this is a production of cornell
university
so i'm general fazio i'm the
apple rootstop reader for the joint
breeding program
between the usdars and cornell
university
program was established since 1968
that's
close to the year when i was born so
i'm the second generation breeder in
this in this program
and uh
apple rootstocks
i bet
only a few of you know what apple
rootstocks are and so i'm going to
demonstrate a little bit uh
the concept of baffled rootstocks and
their importance
first of all
um
this is an apple tree
it has apples hanging this is actually a
fuji apple tree
but as you can see um you go all the way
down to the bottom right here
and you look at the bark and the bark
suddenly changes to a different type of
bark
this is the graft union
this is the rootstock this is called the
scion
of course it's joined by grafting so
we're actually breeding the root system
and this first part of
uh
we call it the rootstock shank or
trunk
and
what do we breed for
initially we breed for disease
resistance
then we look at
other parameters like yield and
dwarfing
early bearing also called percocity
we look at mineral nutrient
absorption by the root system and their
translocation up into the science
we
have ventured into
also selecting for
improved
winter hardiness and
and also
we can
select for
improved nutrient balance
the breeding program was initially
established because of a
scourge that's
north american in origin it's called
fire blight
and
if i go right over here i have a little
example of what fire blight looks like
right here you see this little
shepherd's crook
this is
the typical sign of
apple tree that has been hit by fire
blight
the problem with fire blight is that
okay fine it hits up here in the top
part of the tree and the scion
but fire blight actually
travels all the way down to the
rootstock in like a couple weeks
maybe sometimes three weeks
and if the rootstock is sensitive
um
it just dies
so i've seen orchards uh with thousands
of trees
uh that were grafted on one of our
traditional rootstocks that's been
around for about 300 years
called m9 and i've seen
thousands of trees dead because of this
disease fire blight
so that's why
that's one of the reasons why the
program was established
it was also established to
uh do something else
and that is
uh be more dwarfing and more productive
so one of the
big traits that we
breed for
is dwarfing
this tree right here
and
this tree back here
were planted at the same time
the only difference between these two
trees the same it's the same science the
same sign variety but the only
difference between these two trees
is the rootstock and the rootstock
genetic potential to dwarf the tree
we've discovered the
genetic loci that
contribute to this dwarfing character
and we currently use microscience
breeding to select for those in their
populations
but
when i was talking about dwarfing
the major dwarfing rootstock m9
is highly susceptible to
several diseases including fire blight
and replant disease complex and so
[Music]
the breeding program
was established and it has
perhaps the only
apple rootstocks that were bred for
resistance to fire blight and
replant disease complex so in addition
to dwarfing
we also select for a related trait which
is called early bearing
and
yield or crop load
so
as you can see with this young dwarf
tree
we can count 1 2 four five six seven
eight you know maybe we have uh we're
hanging about 30 to 50 apples on this
tree
whereas
this
uh more vigorous tree
on a different roof stocks that does not
have the same density of apples and
flowers
and
and that is
another trait
that we can select for in the root
system in the rootstock but then it
exemplifies itself or displays itself
in the top part which is the cyan
so you can imagine
now the complexity of breeding apple
rootstocks we're measuring most of the
traits
on a different genotype if you can
imagine
joining two genotypes together
two apple genotypes you have
one that hit that has
certain characteristics in terms of
hormones and
gene expression
uh
also the way the tissue is arranged and
then it's joined with another genotype
that has completely or somewhat
different characteristics in terms of
how it perceives those hormones or
perceives water status or or something
else and so
whenever you make
one combination
and you measure
everything like yield and
precalcity or early bearing
in one combination
things may be slightly different when
you join
in with another
cyan variety so
something that is
good for fuji apples
may not be so good for another type of
apple like gala or honey crisp or
you know some of the new ones uh
snapdragon from
from uh
cornell
and uh and therefore we have to some
what account for these differences
it becomes
pretty complex
20 years ago up to 20 years ago we used
to have a monoculture pretty much a
monoculture of m9 root stocks that was
the
rootstock that was
uh applied in
about 90 percent of uh
newer dwarfing apple orchards in the u.s
we've been able to transition through uh
by releasing new geneva root stocks that
are disease resistant and
and uh more productive we've been able
to transition to
a much more diverse uh portfolio of
apple rootstocks
so we have about
12 apple root stocks that our program
released and they've all they all have
fairly different applications
some are more vigorous but yet
still
very
yield efficient
and
some are less vigorous or
promote a smaller tree
but are able to
produce larger fruit in certain cases we
have come up with a concept that's
called designer rootstock
or a rootstock that's designed
to fit in certain circumstances
for example
we use
we could use a very different rootstocks
here in new york compared to washington
state
and then compared to brazil where we
actually do have a good production of
our roost stocks and then compared to
south africa and california and
pennsylvania and maryland
why
well because
soil quality is different
or the soils are different the water
quality and the amount of water
available is also different
this orchard right here is not irrigated
and we it's completely reliant on
on natural
rain water whereas most of the orchards
out west in washington state idaho and
oregon all the way down to california
require irrigation
and so
that is also a
something that we have to account for
when we breed because
it's the root system that absorbs the
water the nutrients and everything else
and sends them up to the to the scion
and so where
how
that irrigation is done is influencing
the way a rootstock performs
so
with apple roots we're actually breeding
two
different crops
and
why do i say that
well
we're breeding to generate
these
little things these little sticks these
are actually root stocks
and so we have a
a point in the nursery where
we propagate these we can propagate by
micropropagation but also by
stooling and so the soothing properties
are also important so we breed for
that
part of the growth cycle where we have
mother plants that are cut down
every year to produce these liners
rootstock liners
and then we breed for the phase in the
orchard
so they they move from a rootstock
nursery to a finished tree nursery these
root stocks they get joined by grafting
and
budding and i'll demonstrate right that
right now we'll start with a rootstock
uh liner and this will be planted in the
ground and and this is the the ground
lining
a very expert person will
make a
incision like this in another incision
like this
hold on
and expose the uh
the cambium
okay
just like that
and then
they'll go back and they'll have a
bundle of uh bud sticks
and the buds have not quite
they're not quite completely developed
but i think i can
find one that is somewhat ready over
here
it'll take a bud and this is what the
bud the next year's bud looks like
and they'll make a the same incision on
that bud
and cut it off the tree
cut off the branch just like that
okay
and voila
here is
the bud
and now
we're gonna join it just like that
with the rootstock
and this gets tied and and
covered for
a few uh a few weeks
and when all of the
tissues have
um
developed
a you know it looks like a scab
essentially basically it's
parenchymatics tissue that that develops
once it's all healed up
um
it overweight we overwintered the the
rootstock and then
cut the rootstock right here
and this new bud
will become the new tree
and
um we'll have a new fuji tree fuji apple
tree now
you if you wanted a fuji on one side and
then and a gal on the other side just
put
a fuji
apple on one side and a gal on the other
side
i've seen people do that
but this is the way it's done
commercially
and
there are probably 25 to 30 million
trees produced in the us every year
and
the vast majority of those trees are
produced by
this simple method by budding
it's hard to find out what's going on in
the
root
because when you pull out a root it's
like uh full of uh dirt and stuff and so
what we're doing here
is uh we're actually
growing apple trees small apple trees
in an aeroponic system that was
developed
well the concept was developed by nasa
but these systems were developed for the
cannabis industry
and we're finding out all kinds of good
stuff from gene expression to
metabolomics and
hormones and and
all sorts of good things about the
physiology and the genetics of apple
roots the very last point
i i would like to make is
why rootstocks
and
why breed rootstocks
and it turns out
that it is the most efficient way
uh to breed fruit trees and actually to
breed other crops other crops are
actually
implementing root stocks in
in their breeding scheme
why do you think it's
so important to breed root stocks
well
you're achieving
an increase in efficiency because
you're not selecting for all the root
traits
that you would be selecting for if you
were breeding a whole plant
and so you're separating the root traits
from the trays that make this apple very
very tasty and good
and also
other trays that belong to the top part
the scion
and
thereby gaining a huge amount of
efficiency so imagine
breeding
10 traits in the scion fruit shape fruit
color and
let's see what other things so that they
have bricks
so sweetness the crunchiness of the
apple
and all of those are controlled by many
many genes so imagine selecting for all
those traits
and then having to add
fire blight resistance in this in the
uh
and then resistance to phytophthora
resistance to pythium resistance to uh
rhizoctonia and uh and then the you know
complex uh
replant disease uh resistance and
and then dwarfing and dwarfing is two
two and a half genes
i know i know half a gene doesn't sound
right but
there are slightly modifiers and then
you start breeding
for the root system to absorb more
potassium be more efficient with calcium
absorption and and all these other
traits that are mounted up and if you
had to combine both cyan and rootstocks
together
you know it take more than 50 years yeah
or
a couple of medium plants
and
some very smart guy doing
uh whole
genome
selection
instead
the two
items are separated and then joined by
grafting
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu